ever i just want to show you something
quickly I've been asked this question
twice now not this exact question about
close enough and I really hate just
giving an answer and I oh that's that's
it like I want to push on it what's good
what and why is it okay so I don't just
know what the answer is but why it is
what it is okay so humor me please
what's the derivative or get one is
don't simplify it just tell me what's
the derivative of log to it looks like
it is you do chain rule and that gives
you that would look our boys in the
light okay Lord of 7x okay so you're
getting a bit tired of this right I'm do
it online okay now what this is me right
why is it like if I doesn't something
wrong like why is it that all of these
derivatives are the same trap because if
we look at the exponential function if
we were derived a traditional again is
the expansion project ukrainian as
yes yes I can good good good so where
they get along strike here right when we
were looking at the fib fib twin love of
logs the Exponential's right you're
different share that and just keep
getting the same thing back right so we
shouldn't be that surprised that there
is some kind of similar behavior here
still doesn't get to the bottom of
what's going on right all of these are
the same derivative right now we already
have language for this if you go from
being and you in Reverse you're
integrating right so you're integrating
something like this right so which one
of these is it and the answer is well
before we even learnt about what
information was we did
antidifferentiation right and that's
what we introduced this I do you
remember that where did this come from
why did we introduce this before was
called the constant of integration we
learnt it about anti differentiation why
did it appear there's a good opinion to
life by the same graph but shifted up
and down exactly when you look at this
you say wall that's the grade yet tell
me where I came from right there's a
whole bunch of different functions when
you could have come from we said there's
a whole family often right so I like for
example x squared plus 1 x squared plus
5x great 100 they're all the same family
of primitives right in other words this
this is these can you see
see why pink think about your logs is
anyone connecting with it yet do you
have standards fools and then that's
just look 100 plus we started if you
remember your log wars which admittedly
we haven't spent all that much time
revising because I hope that they come
out as you work on them right what a
lobby is is its amount of time right
however long it takes you to virtual hug
repackage eyes and then X hydrofoils
right or you could just throw for that
amount of time and in that amount of
time separately I put look at this guy
it's just a constant in fact all of
these the one the to the 7 100 even then
they look like they're multiplying they
are not multiplying they are adding it's
wet logs work right so therefore
actually in fact if we want to grab all
of these they just all sit on top of
each other and varying distances or just
so just think every about the results
you get like if you look at this do you
think I think I'm doing something wrong
but I'm convinced I'm doing it right try
and get to the bottom of it is that
there's something going on there if you
remember your log walls that will help
you want index laws as well for the same
reason